hey guys you know I love talking about
free speech and political correctness so
Jerry Seinfeld was on ESPN radio this
week and then he was on Late Night with
Seth Meyers and he was talking about
what he called the creepy PC culture
that's happening across colleges in the
United States and talking about how
everyone is offended by jokes so we've
talked a lot about this on the show and
that people shouldn't get offended by
jokes or cartoons and all that stuff
Jerry the interesting thing about Jerry
is Jerry is the most politically correct
comic there is do you know Jerry
Seinfeld's political beliefs on anything
No so it seems ironic that he's saying
this but if a guy like Jerry Seinfeld is
realizing that the PC police are out and
that everyone's offended all the time
and outrage all the time then what does
that do for the comics that are really
trying to get close to the line and the
ones that are trying to push where the
line is and do anything that's edgy it's
a really scary proposition so when Jerry
Seinfeld mr. vanilla is on board that
we're getting a little too politically
correct then yeah we really are anyway
I'm really curious what you guys think
about this you know what I think about
free speech use it you are allowed to
offend people
you're supposed to offend people you
have a right to free speech not the
right to not be offended I won't know
what you guys think let me know in the
comments write a blue